can a psychological Thriller work as a
musical can a high budget action flick
be successfully broken into two parts
we'll be sure to find out once these
2024 films hit screens if anything
should put directors Anthony and Joe
Russo's upcoming sci-fi epic the
electric State on viewers watch lists
it's the extraordinary cast Millie Bobby
Brown and Chris Pratt are slated to play
the lead roles but it's in The
Supporting Cast where things get really
enticing the film will feature an
ensemble cast of actors in both live
action and voice over roles including
kiwei Quan Brian Cox and Jenny slate on
top of all that former Seinfeld star
Jason Alexander will also be making a
rare major Motion Picture appearance in
the future
make me do your leader
outside of the cast it'll also be
interesting to see how the russos
translate the Striking imagery of Simon
stalinhog's electric State graphic novel
into a film adaptation the images from
the source material make use of
evocative deep blue hues and feature
massive robots lingering around in
everyday environments leaving a lot of
opportunities for the filmmakers to
produce equally striking cinematography
through which they can tell this unique
sci-fi story Adrian Molina's days at
Pixar date back to 2007 when he worked
as an animator on the end titles of
Ratatouille since then Molina has moved
up the ranks at Pixar to provide
additional screenplay material for the
good dinosaur and Monsters University he
also served as co-director and
screenwriter on the 2017 Smash Hit Coco
come 2024 Molina will move up to solo
directing Pixar's upcoming title Elio
details on the project are minimal but
according to Pixar's official Twitter
account the film will be a Sci-Fi yarn
about a young boy who winds up in the
far reaches of outer space and gets
mistaken by alien life forms as the
Ambassador for Earth Coco was such an
extraordinary and well-renowned feature
that the prospect of any new production
from Molina should be enough of a reason
for Pixar fans to celebrate it'll also
be interesting to see Pixar's next Take
On The World of sci-fi storytelling The
Domain in the studio has explored
sporadically throughout the years to
varying results for example Wally was a
fairly resounding success when it came
out in 2008. however their more recent
attempt at a Sci-Fi story 2022's light
year received mixed reviews at best with
so many promising elements even this
early into its production Elio has the
potential to be another story chapter in
Molina's prolific career at Pixar it's
been a while since audiences got to
explore the vast and imaginative world
of Miles Morales depicted in 2018
Spider-Man into the spider-verse however
not only is a sequel to that movie
imminent but a pair of follow-ups are
also on the docket the second sequel set
in the spider-verse universe will be
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse which
is scheduled to hit theaters in March
2024. given out scan details are
available about the first of these
sequels Spider-Man across the
spider-verse it's no surprise that
beyond the spider burst is shrouded in
mystery most information about which
characters from the first two films will
appear in the third is still not public
knowledge though it has been confirmed
that Jason schwartzman's spot will serve
as the main villain in the 2024 film
still the vibrancy of this world makes
the concept of spending more time in the
Multiverse of spider people incredibly
exciting plus the title beyond the
spider-verse suggests some truly trippy
storytelling possibilities could be in
store for audiences maybe even a
live-action mashup we'll have to wait
and see to find out more about what this
particular movie has up its sleeve but
if the quality of into the spider-verse
is any indication audiences should get
stoked for what beyond the spider verse
has in store
look I made a promise so I have to keep
it the world of a quiet place is poised
to expand significantly with the
forthcoming spin-off a quiet place day
one while details about this film's plot
are still largely Under Wraps it does
appear that new characters beyond the
original quiet place protagonists will
be taking center stage with Lupita
nuango and Joseph Quinn lined up to play
two of the new film's leads there's also
change of foot behind the scenes with
pig writer and director Michael sonoski
taking over John krasinski's place as
director with such vast shifts and
casting and Leadership this next
installment to the quiet place Universe
could offer something noticeably
different from its predecessors the
title suggests that moviegoers will be
returning to the very start of the noise
sensitive Alien Invasion a backdrop
briefly explored in the prologue to a
quiet place part 2. exploring how humans
react to their suddenly changing world
could certainly provide a fresh spin for
the franchise especially since
tsarnowski proved to be extremely gifted
at exploring Humanity's ability to
Grapple with loss Pig Ethan Hunt the
protagonist of the expansive Mission
Impossible Series has had to pull off
some incredible Feats throughout this
franchise however soon Tom Cruise's
iconic character will have to complete
an especially daunting task nailing a
two-part Blockbuster the next
installment in the mission impossible
franchise dead reckoning is going to be
split across a pair of Motion Pictures
the second of which will arrive in June
2024 as titles like Divergent Allegiant
have proved in the past taking one story
and splitting it across two movies can
go very wrong very fast however if hunt
could climb the world's tallest building
and survive then it stands to reason he
might manage to make dead reckoning a
satisfying multi-film experience
one promising aspect of the second part
of dead reckoning is that it'll feature
some cast members that won't be around
for the first installment including Nick
Offerman and Holt mcalleny the presence
of new faces indicates that the second
part of dead reckoning might just offer
something unique rather than act as a
rehash of the first part that's just one
of the countless reasons moviegoers are
on the edge of their seats waiting for
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part 2
to show up in theaters
after dominating the Academy Awards bong
Joon ho returns to both science fiction
Cinema and English language storytelling
with his 2024 directorial effort Mickey
17 based on the book Mickey 7 by Edward
Ashton Mickey 17 Stars the endlessly
versatile Robert Pattinson as a man
tasked with working on an expedition to
colonize a far-off ice planet from there
if prior Jun ho movies are any
indication the film is likely to take
some unpredictable turns and project
potent social commentary on the world
around us there are still so few details
on what this adaptation will look and
feel like but Jun Ho's incredible body
of work makes it difficult not to get
penalized by this project immediately if
the film's elevator pitch wasn't enough
to excite you the rest of the cast just
might aside from Robert Pattinson taking
on the lead role Tony Collette Stephen
Yoon naomiacki and Mark Ruffalo are all
listed as Supporting Cast Pattinson has
always shown a penchant for working with
beloved autors like David Cronenberg
Robert Eggers and Claire Dany so it's
incredibly exciting to imagine what
he'll accomplish as a performer working
under the filmmaker responsible for
parasite needless to say there are more
than a few reasons to be pumped for the
release of this legendary director's
next cinematic effort furiosa is the new
George Miller movie that fact alone
should send it rocketing toward the very
top of any list of the most anticipated
movies of 2024 the fact that it's a
George Miller directorial effort set in
the Mad Max World however makes the
prospect of this cinematic experience
even more appetizing this time around
the character of furiosa from Mad Max
Fury Road will not be portrayed by
Charlize Theron but by Anya Taylor Joy
this leading lady has been on a hot
streak with her work in movies and TVs
including notable 2022 titles like the
northmen and the menu so the idea of her
getting to work under the direction of
George Miller sounds downright
extraordinary care for demonstration
English actor Tom Burke will also appear
in the film's cast while Burke may not
be a household name yet he delivered
extraordinary work on Joanna Hogs the
souvenir with a background largely in
British Indies and TV it'll be extremely
revelatory to see what he can do with a
much larger canvas at his disposal
beyond the cast which also includes
Chris Hemsworth furiosa is bound to be
home to a practically realized spectacle
that only Miller would have the gallon
imagination to pull off if he manages to
capture even a fraction of the Fury Road
magic then furiosa will be only the
latest example of why any new George
Miller movie should be met with great
anticipation the Planet of the Apes
franchise is seen seemingly constant
updates over the course of the last few
decades which might make viewers think
that this Saga would be running on fumes
creatively however the most recent
Trilogy of features from this universe
two of which were helmed by the Batman
director Matt Reeves were some of the
most exciting and daring entries to date
that's not to say Planet of the Apes is
incapable of turning out a dud movie Tim
Burton's 2001 film Planet of the Apes
was certainly a lacking contribution to
the franchise however there's clearly a
lot of creative longevity within this
universe which makes the prospect of the
2024 installment Kingdom of the Planet
of the Apes sound especially appetizing
according to deadline Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes will take place
decades after the events of War for the
Planet of the Apes though any further
plot details are wrapped up in secrecy
for now however the idea of a
continuation of the story first
established in Rise of the Planet of the
Apes is certainly compelling
additionally with West ball as the new
director there's plenty of possibility
for some fresh new visuals to be
incorporated into this installment
what's more Owen Teague is tapped to
play the main ape and his remarkable
work in features like to Leslie makes us
enthusiastic to see what'll do in a
motion capture role to summarize there
are plenty of reasons to go bananas for
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes after
finally taking on the mantle of Captain
America in the final episode of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Sam Wilson
will get to headline his own feature
film in Captain America New World Order
directed by loose film maker Julius Ona
Captain America New World Order promises
to continue some of the most intriguing
elements of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier however New World Order is also
primed to connect Wilson's Captain
America to broader parts of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe mythology like the
long-awaited return of Tim Blake
Nelson's Samuel Stern from The
Incredible Hulk this Marvel Studios
feature is also positioned to include
the debut appearance of Harrison Ford as
general Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross just
the presence of such a legendary acting
giant should put new world order on many
a viewers radar However the fact that it
will also function as an opportunity to
see the new Captain America soar as a
big screen leading man is without a
doubt the primary cause of the buzz that
has already begun surrounding this film
The Dragon Warrior is back in March 2024
Poe will return for another adventure in
Kung Fu Panda 4. that's all that anybody
in the general public knows about this
forthcoming sequel with even key details
like the creative team behind this
follow-up shrouded in mystery however
ambiguity certainly won't keep people
from getting excited about all the
possibilities of seeing Poe go on
another Epic Quest after all the first
three Kung Fu Panda movies are among the
strongest titles in the Dreamworks
Animation Canon with Kung Fu Panda 2
standing out as a sequel that took the
franchise in a new tonal Direction
without losing the core ingredients that
made the original installation so
lovable you gotta let go of that stuff
from the past because it just doesn't
matter
if the Kung Fu Panda franchise could
pull off a sequel as good as Kung Fu
Panda 2 then there's a good chance Kung
Fu Panda 4 could also be something
special plus recent Dreamworks Animation
titles like the bad guys and Puss in
Boots The Last Wish have been remarkably
strong in overall quality if that hot
streak of creativity extends to this
forthcoming Kung Fu Panda feature then
audiences should prepare themselves for
another totally awesome addition to the
Kung Fu Panda Saga the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has often concerned itself with
totally unknown superheroes who have
never been considered for the big screen
before like the Guardians of the Galaxy
or the eternals however one of its
upcoming 2024 titles will be anchored by
a superhero who has not only appeared in
a future film before but actually led a
Trilogy of movies across the late 1990s
and early 2000s a new incarnation of
Blade once played by Wesley Snipes is
headed to the MCU with this version of
the character being played by mahershala
Ali according to the Hollywood Reporter
the two-time Oscar winner has such a
deep passion for the character that he
outright asked Marvel Studios to let him
play The Vampire Hunter while Ali's
commitment to Blade has never wavered in
the years since he signed onto the role
the movie itself has experienced several
hardships on its way to the screen
including the loss of original director
Hassan Tariq while those setbacks have
been discouraging the choice of young
demolish as the new director of the film
inspires a lot of confidence that this
feature could still turn out to be
something special additionally Marvel
Studios has successfully delivered
several Classics in spite of turbulent
Productions in the past so there are
still a few good reasons to remain
hopeful that Ali stint is blade will
turn out to be a success the Fall Guy
originated as a TV show starring Lee
Majors that aired on ABC for five
seasons in the 1980s in March 2024
though it'll be released as an action
movie headlined by Ryan Gosling and
helmed by Bullet Train director David
Leach however Gosling isn't the only
recognizable name in this action feature
Emily Blunt Stephanie Shu Winston Duke
Aaron Taylor Johnson and Hannah
waddingham are all set to round out the
ensemble cast The Fall Guy is so far out
from release that many aspects of the
production are still unknown including
just how much or how little this motion
picture will adhere to its source
material however any opportunity to
watch Ryan Gosling punch people sounds
like a good time at the movies and The
Supporting Cast sounds Ace leech's
filmmaking career has had its ups and
downs but the best of his Works have had
a propulsive energy and Zippy atmosphere
that's difficult to resist plus his Peak
effort as an auteur 2017's atomic blonde
also featured incredible fight
choreography which could indicate the
Fall Guy will feature cool combat
sequences at the very least all in all
the ingredients are there for this movie
to be much more than a rehash of a 1980s
TV staple the original Joker may not
have been everybody's cup of tea but it
undeniably separated itself from the
typical comic book movie adaptation
genre and remained a topic of cultural
discussion for years after its release
after years of speculation over whether
or not a sequel to Joker would ever hit
movie theaters its follow-up is
officially scheduled to come out in
October 2024. another key figure from
the villains comic book lore Harley
Quinn will also play a role in the film
with Lady Gaga portraying her on top of
that this follow-up entitled Joker
feliada will also be a musical which
will allow the movie to indulge Gaga's
talents as a singer and differentiate
itself immensely from its predecessor
while the concept of making a joker
sequel may sound predictable it's safe
to assume few fans of the original were
expecting a musical to follow it
additionally the idea of Lady Gaga
playing a version of Harley Quinn with
even a fraction of the energy and
passion the performer brought to her
house of Gucci performance sounds even
more exciting Joker feliada is bound to
be as divisive as his predecessor but it
also sounds like the kind of sequel that
swings for the fences rather than sits
on its laurels hahaha
after Titanic audiences had to wait 12
years for a new James Cameron movie
after Avatar moviegoers had to wait
another 13 years to experience a fresh
vision from the filmmaker a
significantly shorter Wade will exist
between Avatar the way of water and
Cameron's next directorial effort the
Untitled third Avatar movie set for
December 2024 release while Cameron is
keeping many details of Avatar 3 close
to the vest collider reports that this
film will introduce some new characters
poised to make waves throughout the
entire swath of Avatar sequels David
thulis is slated to play a navi
character that will debut in this film
while characters played by Michelle yo
and even Chaplin will also Premiere in
this installment of the franchise
Cameron's penchant for extravagant
spectacle in the first two Avatar movies
should make it clear that this upcoming
sequel will continue working to that
effect it's also exciting to know that
Avatar 3 will introduce new characters
instead of just leaning on familiar
figures from the franchise's past
there's still so much to see on Pandora
and that makes the idea of returning to
the planet in Avatar 3 in immensely
rousing concept especially since it will
arrive much sooner than the previous
films in the series
outstanding
[Music]